hey somebody david l donated 50 bucks
that i want matt to tell me
in detail about the loans he got from
pinnacle bank
pinnacle bank 50 bucks pinnacle bank
yeah this guy this guy knows
this guy knows something he said oh [ __ ]
i've never heard you talk about panic
pinnacle bank oh
listen yeah i don't remember hearing
about what does this guy know about so
much fraud through pinnacle bank
and and and specifically specifically
amy early amy earlier was the account
executive
oh now married going by a different name
but she's
she is uh following me on uh
facebook um so i see her her every once
in
a
while
so she sees your stuff she sees my stuff
you think it's her oh i know it's her
positivity um but yeah she uh oh
we we did a ton of fraud on pinnacle
banks oh yes
how much fraud like what do you think a
million two million
milk 10 10 million 15 million
just pinnacles i'm talking about
pinnacle it was pinnacle bank corp and
it was owned
by pinnacle it was owned by a guy named
uh
gary vaughan i remember it because it
was
it sounded it was very close bond
and i said joke all the time vond gary
vaughn um
so uh yeah man listen they caught us
on on over and over again committing
fraud too
really left and right gary caught us one
time one time we got caught with like it
was like
it was a couple several million dollars
and they'd already sold
a few million dollars to household bank
and then they caught us with like a
million dollars in fraud
and they sold it they knew it was
fraught and they sold it
to household bank again another one
that was like the industry they called
up he was a little threatening
when he realized that i was like look i
can't cut you a check for for the money
that you
thought you caught so i don't know what
if you're expecting i'm gonna cut your
check for like a million dollars you're
you're wrong that's not gonna happen
yeah and he was like no but you know
we're gonna go ahead and put this in a
package that we're
selling so if it comes back on us though
you have to agree you'll help me get rid
of any loans that come back on us of
course
of course sure what am i going to say
yeah no oh
yeah no no yeah call the fbi [ __ ] you
of course i'm gonna of course gary you
can rely on me of course
i'm trustworthy and amy would always run
interference
she was always she'd call you up and be
like listen this is what they just found
out
this is what they know i don't know what
you're gonna say but this is what they
know
and i'd be like okay and then the phone
would ring like five minutes later the
phone would ring boom i'd be like yeah
what's it and i'd have a
i'd already have a story completely
ready what oh
absolutely like i i didn't know
beforehand you don't know what to do
you're [ __ ] yeah
you had to drop they asked did she go to
prison too
amy no no she got enough when pinnacle
eventually went under i like to think by
no fault of mine
um i don't know that's true though
i'm sure you were a part of that when
they eventually went under she just got
a job working for
citibank you know she said group city
banks yeah oh yeah
reputable bank um
and uh yeah she went to work for them
god there was a chick that worked there
named nash what was her name
we all went to dinner a few times anyway
yeah
uh but in detail my god bro we had
cancelled checks we had
fake pay stubs fake i mean that just
there was
so much fraud that we put through and we
knew all the underwriters
they would come down they'd take us to
like they literally when they after gary
caught us with a couple million dollars
in fraud
a week later he flew down and took me
and three of the brokers out to uh
uh out to dinner and he said what
he actually said during that meeting he
got drunk
and he actually said um
oh i was just thinking of something i
can't even say say it no no i can't say
it
it's not amy anyway um because i always
liked amy i was kind of had a crush on
amy you did yeah
she's available now yeah she's not she's
not okay
she's married uh that's i um so
gary got drunk and i remember gary we
were talking about fraud and gary said
to be honest he is i don't care how much
fraud goes through that company because
as long as it doesn't come back on us
because as long as it goes through our
underwriting department and they don't
catch it
because then it doesn't come back on us
he said if it does go into foreclosure
he goes i don't care how much fraud goes
through that place because we know
fraud's going through the place
he told me one time he caught a guy with
fraud he taught caught a guy with like a
250
000 fraud like literally they'd fund the
loan and like when they went to go sell
it to their
secondary investor the secondary
investor caught the it was fraud
like it was blatant it was like w2s pay
stubs like
the phone number that verified the um
the comp that verified the guy's
employment
like literally like went to the owner of
the company i mean so he called him up
he's like oh i had him he was done
i told him i was gonna call the fbi this
and that
gary said look we have to pay x amount
of dollars to maintain
that loan until we can sell it now
you're saying now we can't sell it so
it's stuck on our books
and we have to pay a fee the longer it
stays on there
here's what the fee is so he said he
came up with some ridiculous [ __ ]
like five or six thousand dollars a
month he was this guy had paid this like
five thousand dollars a month
for like four or five months and really
the money was just going into gary's
just taking five grand just
five grand and he said i don't care if
he pays that fee forever
he said eventually he said the guy was
paying it until eventually the guy
got they sold the house or refinanced
the house he said oh he's up to like 20
20 35 000
at this point he was laughing about it i
mean he was drunk and we were like
i was thinking this guy is [ __ ]
vicious
whatever happened to that guy i mean his
company went under
yeah i'm sure he turned around and
opened up another what was his name
gary vaughn gary vaughn gary somebody in
the chat
find out what the [ __ ] gary vaughn is
yeah for real we need him on the podcast
we need him on the [ __ ]
i bet he's got some story oh yeah gary
vaughn is now the ceo of citibank
where the hell is gary vaughn somebody
find gary vaughn for us
didn't you just do some [ __ ]
commercial for some home security
company
yeah yeah right so a home security
company
fired you and flew you out to oklahoma
right well it was it's
called uh it's called um home title lock
so it's like life lock but for your home
so it protects
people against the crimes that i
actually committed i actually met newt
gingrich
what yeah nate gingrich right like newt
gingrich was like 100 years old
when i was young and so when they told
me newt gingrich is going to be
interviewing you i went
he's still alive and they were like he's
77 but yeah he's actually he's he's
he's doing good he's doing well he's i
was like that's
nuts wow what was that like it was it
was fine he was you know nice guy there
were two fbi agents there it's nice to
talk to an fbi agent when
they're not looking for you um so
you know i met a bunch of people it's
like a huge production they flew me in
i stayed two nights uh i only worked one
day
so you know it was it was it was cool it
was in oklahoma city oklahoma which is
really a nice city like i really felt
like oklahoma city was like going to be
like
scummy bro everywhere i went nice
clean everybody's polite well this is
really very nice
huh i've never been i mean i've been
before but it was
i when i was flown in by the bop and
conair
and they unloaded me into the holdover
for two weeks and then loaded me back on
the plane
and flew me out so i didn't get to see a
lot of the city on that trip
you get to see many sites huh no no i
couldn't matter of fact it was freezing
cold when i
when they caught me too so i couldn't
the windows i remember were frozen up
so you couldn't even see out the window
it was all white so i got to see nothing
that's that bites yeah yeah you know
i